Watch them hit a few balls.
Alright, so tell me your names again.
I'm Venus.
I'm Serena.
So, what do you think?
I wrote me a 78-page plan for their whole career before they were even born.
Yeah, baby yeah!
If these girls are so great, how come I've never heard of them?
They're from Compton.
It's okay, they're just not used to seeing good-looking people like us.
She's nervous, take a step up.
Maybe she ought to take a few more steps up.
Just get someplace safe.
I think you might just have the next Michael Jordan.
Oh no, brother man, I got me the next two.
This next step you're about to take, you're not going to just be representing you.
You would be representing every little black girl on Earth.
I'm not gonna let you down.
How could you?
This world ain't never had no respect for Richard Williams,...
...but they're going to respect y'all.
You're going to walk out there with your head up.
You are a champion, and the whole world knows.
The most dangerous creature on this whole earth is a woman who knows how to think.
Yes, daddy.
Ain't nothing she can't do.
Are you going to show them how dangerous you are?
Yes.
Venus and Serena are going to shake up this world.